市場氣氛都會微妙的轉變
前一陣子大家就說
利多好像都有發酵了
但最近有很多的產業利空
在這一週
本來覺得沒什麼的
也開始在做發酵了
所以這邊的氣氛改變
就要來請教凱哥了
因為氣氛改變
有時候往往醞釀的就是機會
我們不是說麥威爾
跟谷歌要合作嗎
大家想說那你這個博通發哥
可能就會被一腳踹出去
發哥連跌其實就是給機會
再來未知素這家公司
很多人知道他是做未素的
但現在是薄膜的大公司
他現在要斷工中國
奇怪咧
他斷工中國
我們台場已經為什麼PCB跌一片
對 所以就是行情
當市場進入比較盤整
或空頭的時候
基本上利空
他就會影響到股價
所以就是利多不漲
但是利空會跌
基本上
Maveo跟Google的合作
確實他把薄通踢出去
是 對
真的踢出去啦
他真的把薄通
給踢到門外
也沒有踢很遠
但是發哥也莫名其妙被提出去
我們等一下看一下
基本上我覺得他有點被挫殺了
好
那麼這個行情基本上
因為其實我們現在油價很尷尬的位置
尷尬 真的
油價很尷尬
大家覺得好像快要怎麼樣
快要打了
所以其實市場上有點
彎彎
其實我們看到投行也是這樣子
投行現在轉去高股息嘛
總統講高股息
8月19的這一天
其實川普發了一個重訊
他說我要對他怎樣
我要對伊朗實施經濟制裁
我沒有要真的去打他
所以這個搞不好會有一些變化
就是大家希望打
可是最後是沒有打
所以這股市街的氣氛怎麼樣
就會開始緩起
大盤角度其實你看
他其實就是守在這個位置
其實他守在這個位置
所以我一直覺得
其實這個大盤有高手在戶
是
對 已經戶三天了
戶三天
其實你看從這個角度可以看得出來
其實他在前三天就開始打角
雖然大家覺得不太看好
都覺得會跌會跌
可是它怎樣
它就慢慢的拉起來
目前就是利多不漲
但是利空會跌
但是呢
邁威爾他跟這個TPU
這個東西就是他跟
Google要進行一個深度的合作
所以他要讓Google認股
認股 對
認股這件事情他想說
我們的發哥都沒有讓Google認股了
居然馬菲有讓Google認股
所以他覺得說
這個好像近了一點
這個就怎樣
遠了一點
但其實你可以看一件事情
就是現在就是博通過去統包 Google TPU
這事情看起來不會再發生了
因為你看聯發科進來了
Mavell進來了
AMD也想要進來
所以表示 Google TPU 這個比怎麼樣
非常的大
所以它不會只有一家
也不會只有兩家
它會有很多家都進來
那現在大家看的就是
Mavell對聯發科的影響是什麼
其實Mavell最強的其實是在通訊
尤其是在網通的部分
所以其實大家看Mafel都是看光通
光通
對 所以只要Mafel大漲通通就會跟著大漲
所以它跟發哥走的是不一樣的路徑
所以聯發哥在這次的過渡TPU
它是一個主導的地位
所以目前看起來在這個世代
到今年到明年看起來都是聯發哥主導
所以AMD是要進入下一個世代
所以也不會是馬上的
所以在Mafel
邁有消息沒出來之前
其實AMD這消息就已經先出來了
所以這個聯發科就連續被打了好幾根
那這事情對聯發科會不會有什麼大影響看起來今天是漲的所以感覺是影響不太大但是你看其實我認為影響比較大的會是台灣的這兩家 ASIC
為什麼
因為過去其實
這個東西其實大家沒有很重視
所以大廠都沒有跳進來
現在是AMD也要進來
麥克也要進來
所以告訴你
創意跟世新KY
就會有一點點的尷尬
不過還好是
因為這兩家其實都
是守在台積電的旁邊
而且背後
對啊創意台積電子公司
新科外亞馬遜也有投資他
是 就是說
因為大家最終都還來台積投片
所以這兩家
還是有一個
晉升的一個
互衛的一個角色
所以他就不容易怎樣被取代掉
不能被取代掉
我們看連發科
你看 疊好幾天今天怎麼樣
今天頭新發覺自己好像殺錯了
這邊真的很可憐啊 對不對
今天頭新突然發現自己好像錯了
連續賣了好多天
發哥的五年
你看今天這樣殺生融融
其實他今天反而怎麼樣
覺得不能賣
因為什麼
外資根本就沒有大賣
外資根本沒有大賣
但是聯發科的型態
日K 是這樣走
這是他的週K
那其實你可以看到
他過去漲了一段之後
其實就是在反應Google TPU
所以他就回檔做一個修正
所以他在這個區間裡面
所以我覺得
其實他下來
其實給你一個很好的買點
很好的買點
只是說你要怎麼去操作它
那你看這邊的大量大概在這裡
所以這邊我覺得就是有點超跌了
超跌 是可以留意的
這是研發科的部分
那確實最近是投信賣的比較多
投信賣的比較多 不過無所謂
因為投信下來就是會追高殺低
這是投信的特色
怎麼突然出現了凱哥的金句呢
所以我說創新高你追你也害怕
打下來跌你也害怕
那怎麼辦
我們要看這個形態
這是事實
就是我們要抓住這個形態
所以我跟大家講說
其實你要先找什麼
領先創新高的
領先創新高的族群告訴你什麼
我是有料的
我最強
所以你不用理會現在
這個利率要怎麼走
油價要怎麼走
不重要
因為他們會領先創新高
最少要說你
他根本沒有在在乎這些因素
所以反而是什麼
有利空消息的壓回
就是給你好一個買點
所以我們來看一下後面的部分
就是你看
載板這個未知數
他要斷供什麼
其實他斷供的是中國的PT載板
那到底
到底我們今天為什麼PTB跌那麼慘
因為有利空嘛
大家覺得好像怎麼樣
它的料會沒有辦法完全供給
我們可能也會不夠
對 但是想太多了
想太多
因為台灣其實確實在
ABF要積極的擴充
對啊 它料不夠啦
對 所以他告訴大陸說
我沒有辦法供給你這麼多
因為我要先給台灣
這樣解釋就舒服了
這對台灣是很好的一件事情
所以大家不要往復面想
大家老是只要一看到利空
就想要怎麼樣
就想要賣股票 其實這很危險
那再來就是
目前看起來 我之前講過嘛
其實不管是台積
不管是Intel
他們都造成
ABF載板的良率不夠高
要持續的擴充產能
目前這四家都在擴充
除了南電比較慢一點以外
可是南電現在看起來
也要繼續擴充
對 上半年它還在傻傻的
現在看起來它已經
發覺不太對
因為它再這樣下去
其實緊縮很快就會超越南電
以產能來講
所以南電怎麼可能會
允許這種事情發生
所以而且像今年
他們整個南亞集團賺很多
所以擴充根本不是問題
不是問題
所以它現在積極的擴充產
所以我覺得這些股票殺下來其實是給你一個好的觀察跟買進的一個位置我們可以再看下一頁下一頁是新興先同一載吧今天盤中檔要跌停
盤中跌停
對 比如誰在殺
是投信跟閃戶在殺
外資什麼
外資趁機減便宜
其實外資過去這段時間
已經都一直在買了
一直在買
周先生它其實是已經創新高
壓回
所以我說它是
壓回給你好買點
尤其通常股票是這樣子
過高之後的壓回
通常都是過高壓回來整理的
只是說它是走空
你要擔心的是
過高有沒有爆大量
如果爆大量就要很小心
可是你看星星的大量
其實是出現在這裡
它不是出現在這裡
所以是不太一樣
不太一樣
接下來看景碩
剛剛講快要超車難變了是不是
對 景碩今天也有點被serve到
今天投信跟外資都減滿
但是我覺得
基本上這一波的投信是大買景碩
就是說它過去是不看好的景碩
那過去就看好3037
很比氣3189
有到這種程度嗎 斗哥
他們最愛就是他
最愛是337沒錯
這個感覺就是
OWS不及格的孩子
可是現在感覺好像
有不同的觀點
因為他已經知道說
景碩目前的產能要大幅的擴充
而且景碩在9月份的
在9月份的SIMI的這個展
裡面會秀出來
未來的他們的這個技術論壇
會有下一代的設計的變化
9月的半導體戰很重要
對
所以基本上過去景碩沒有在幹這回事
它沒有技術論壇
是 對
這次要特別要辦技術論壇
所以告訴你
他們有一些比較特別的東西
皮特的東西
那景碩基本上你看這是州
州的大量低就差不多在這裡
它就在這個地方整理
所以它今天也是收一個角
所以我覺得還是可以觀察
而且它離大量低也沒有太遠
也沒有太遠
所以我覺得是打下來是給你買的
但是這一波緊縮
他還是沒有把這個錢高給突破過去
對 因為老大老二都已經過去了
南電信心都已經過高了
所以接下來就換他
對 那真領可能就稍微差遠一點
因為真領他比較多的是
他有HDI的宅報
他有一些消費
HDI的這個PCB版
這個影響會稍微比較大一點
接下來我們看這個是CCO的族群
CCO的族群其實也是
領先創新高的族群
台光電先創高 但壓回了
對 但是你看今天雖然都跟著下來了
可是今天外資也還是站在買方
是
我覺得最重要觀察就是這些科技股
其實投信都是站在賣方
對
因為投信現在就拼命在買高股型
都買中種的股票
所以就把這些通通丟出來
但是趁他們丟出來的時候
就是一個好的買點
其實有時候股票是這樣
就是他們殺下來也不買
等它拉上去的時候你又買不到
好 你看台光電的型態是這樣子
這是日K
之前這個大量出現在這裡
所以這邊基本上它沒有對應的大量
所以它不算是出貨
它沒有出貨
這根大量根本在這邊都沒有出現過
所以它是一個買點
那你週K型態基本上
它上週已經創新高了
所以說它拉回來是要找買點的
那我們來看以日K的型態
我們要怎麼找買點
日K型態因為這一根是大量
所以你只能從上面找買點
上面找買點
就是它如果過這裡
你就還要再買回來
過這裡就6000以上
對 你就還要再買回來
因為目前看起來
它的產能已經領先斗山了
已經領先斗山了 對
那所以它看起來市場還在往這個扣為什麼 因為你不管是輝打或是AMD或是TPU基本上都需要CCL
都需要CCL
所以你可以從CCL的設備廠
就可以知道目前是很吃緊的
凱哥為什麼我不等他
快要回側月線的時候
減左側交易
蠻難的我覺得
因為他已經過高
他就不可能再回到月線
不太容易回那麼深
對 不可能
除非有系統性的
你可以留意就是時日線
我可以留意時日線
所以我們看的下一檔就是台藥
台藥 其實台藥相對講它比較落後
可是你看 投信也在買
投信蠻喜歡台藥的 其實
因為很簡單的邏輯嘛
老大是台光電
台光電的股價除以二 三千二
是
三千二現在在哪裡
現在它才在1920 最高
還要再除以二
還很遠 再除以二就台藥
三千二我覺得啦
至少再打個七五折應該就有機會啦
打個七五折
所以投信其實一直很喜歡它
但是它建議也稍微弱一點
因為它今天把大量高給跌破了
但是我覺得它還在站回去
不用擔心
因為目前它也很積極地在擴產能
所以目前看起來反而是台光
因為它去年就開始擴了
所以今年就沒有什麼在大擴產能的條件
對 但是台藥要注意的是
今天的外資大賣
是
我要講一件事情
這件事情可能對台藥相對會比較不利
什麼事
就是說
第一個是它的大量高跌破
大家要注意的是
J跟大量低不可以跌破
因為它要發CB了
好
又是CB
對 它要發CB了
所以你要注意
它是這裡整理完之後
往上跟著台方電器走呢
還是先下來再往上走
這就要很仔細的觀察
因為最近的外資
已經開始在腳底抹油了
沒關係 等它發CB
我們就叫小哥來講
它的CB到底怎麼樣
好 接著就是
整個PCB相關的材料跟設備工資
尖點
這波反彈弱呢
沒有到很強
對 可是我剛剛講嘛
其實他們都還是很缺
但是你看尖點有一個很尷尬的位置
就是它的大量高出現在這裡
對啊 就這邊量那麼大
所以這裡就有壓力
雖然投信在買
可是也未必能夠穿越這個位置
所以可以觀察一下
就是說到它穿越了
應該是整個都上來
對 因為專徵不是各PCB廠都說很缺嗎
就是說它如果能夠到這裡表示
像CCL 台藥 台光都已經上去了
所以它可以當作是一個落後指標來參考
那PCB的龍頭
基本上最近也開始有一點點回升
頭線為什麼可以砍到這種程度
對 可是它砍完之後
其實它也慢慢有一點買回來的味道
它也沒有一直往下殺
但是你可以注意到就是
你看它大量在這裡
它業績也好
所以表示這邊
它只要再過這個高
它就會往上走
但我覺得它現在是過了
重新站回千元之後
有一點整理的味道
因為畢竟這個形態是很醜
對啦 壓力太大
它形態是這樣子往下走的
所以我覺得它勢必是要回來整理一下
那如果它這邊可以站穩
我覺得是滿不錯的
為什麼
因為這裡有一個大量
這裡也有一根大量
對
如果這根大案高可以站上
那它就應該會往上去
繼續攻
對
我覺得這個型態相對是
比較漂亮
好
因為金像鏈的粉絲也很多
是啊
大家都戴金像鏈
我知道
對
好 大家都期待
能把金像鏈帶回來
這邊非常謝謝凱哥
謝謝趙華